how's it going ahs fans we now have our
first death valley episode under our
belts and by no means was it out of this
world but it did set up a lot of
interesting threads for the next three
episodes to come in this video we'll be
breaking down the trailer for episode 8
so if you haven't seen it yet i've left
a link to it in the description below
we're not going to waste any time
remember to like and subscribe because
here we go first of all apologies on the
quality here fx for some reason takes
forever to release the good quality ones
on their youtube channel so i've had to
make do with this here we have some
suits entering a board room filled with
what appears to be higher-ups in either
the american military and or government
i'm curious if this is edwards air force
base in california where ike eisenhower
was informed the alien crash occurred
nearby not exactly sure how long has
passed since the events of episode 1 but
the president informs the others that
what they heard was true luckily that
aliens exist and that it's being kept
under wraps from the public maria here
who is probably under the control of the
aliens informs them that quote our world
is dying which is likely referring to
the alien home planet this falls in line
with a previous season trailer where she
told them about joining together in some
sort of alliance time is running out
so both are people
we need to create something better
part human
heart us here we can see amelia earhart
unconscious next to a bunch of dead
bodies note eisenhower here on the top
left we aren't sure what killed these
doctors and nurses their heads aren't
exploded so probably not maria it's
possible it could have been one of those
face suckers or perhaps amelia herself
perhaps defending herself from whatever
they were gonna perform on her or it
could be something else entirely either
way she seems uninjured and this might
have to do with the alien baby insider
here's ike holding on to something maybe
a phone maybe something else now this
looks to be back in present day it may
even be what happened to those 4 campers
we saw in episode 7 when they got
abducted i don't however think this is
some sort of alien spacecraft i mean
these machines and what they're laying
on look very human if you notice closely
you can see some movement over here
which appears to be kendall waking up
here is troy alongside kendall and cal
you can even kind of make out a bit of a
baby bump on cal here again no idea how
much time has passed or if these babies
grow at faster rates than normal here is
ike alongside an unconscious amelia
there's already some blood splattered on
the back so it looks like he may be
shooting at a the guard he came in here
with or b whatever the thing that
attacked and killed the doctors and
nurses his aim is pointing pretty low so
it's possible it could be a face sucker
maria tilts her head back perhaps
foreshadowing the alien taking over her
body this also looks like famed actor
steven towalowski but my copy of the
trailer isn't too great to confirm i
think this is troy here but notice how
it's black and white his shirt is also
different than the ones worn by the men
in this shot and even what he's laying
on is different we see these black alien
fingers caress what is to be assumed is
kendall cal is pushed by agents which
leads me to believe the gang heads off
to the doctors next episode only to be
picked up by the government which may
lead them here ike and mammy have a nice
romantic microwave dinner where mammy
remarks she was a bit nervous making
this meal using technology made by quote
them now she's more than likely
referring to the military not aliens
since in the khs news broadcast they
make an effort to note that the
microwave came from military tech it's
the latest in modern electrical cooking
engineers announced today their
intentions to repurpose radar technology
developed during world war ii to nuke
your dinner in no time there's also the
possibility this tech was shared with
the military by the aliens which is why
kendall in episode 7 remarks that more
technology has been developed in the
last 50 years than in the last 20 000
years of humanity combined here's a
pregnant belly with those black alien
fingers again it cuts to kendall who
rubs her neck likely the result of being
injected with whatever is seen in this
season preview that might also be jaime
behind her she also seems to be hooked
up to some sort of yellow iv that is
connected to the ceiling and the last
shot is of angelica ross's character
named theda who appears to be half human
half alien this would follow with
maria's line that humanity and aliens
have to work together to create
something new we also don't know if
theta is any way related to the chemist
and if theta works for the military just
like the chemist did the name theta
comes from the greek alphabet and was
often considered a symbol of death we
also don't know if the events of death
valley take place before or after red
tide so that's what i was able to glean
from this new trailer did i miss
anything let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember daddy loves you very much
you